hey babies it's episode 159 of
congratulations what the frigging [ __ ]
dude it's congratulations episodes one
for every episode 159 started out with a
starter it's all good dude mm-hmm
my voice is scratchy but I don't have a
sore throat so I don't understand really
what's going on it's just kind of
scratching maybe it's the wind in Los
Angeles it's windy is [ __ ] Los
Angeles I don't like the wind wind sucks
dude
anybody who would try to tell you that
the wind is good is just you know
they're like maybe their leaves or some
[ __ ] you know because wind is just not
cool man it's just a shits blowing in
your eyes it's messing up your hair if
it got a little bit if it's a little bit
longer but then like four inches which
minds is Minds do it when I was in
school in New Jersey everybody would say
mines instead of mine mines is better so
yeah I have shows coming up in West Palm
Beach Florida March 20th to the 21st
West Palm Beach Florida playing a Palm
Beach improv working on this new
material you got about 30 minutes of new
material and he's trying to stick in
Sandwich and some old stuff but figure
out how to mana babbitt ax and then
robinson mississippi some reason and
then rohnert park california summer eats
and then doing Brea California for two
weekends in a row because the man the
demand is just poppin spinning time
spinning time and then we got Las Vegas
dates coming up and it's cool man
somebody just asked me when I'm coming
to Minneapolis and I was there two
months ago so it's all good and didn't
my special there and she was like well
put it on your website so people get
tickets and then I wrote well that's how
everybody got their tickets because they
were [ __ ] 4,000 people they're all
good oh good polyhedra host so we're
chillin my babies you know and you can
go get your life trips
hoodies and the most important thing
about the merch dude we know we rock
merch we know them babies have good
merch but you got a [ __ ] wear your
merch to the other comedians shows
particularly Bryan Callen particularly
Theo interesting too anywhere
whoever Josh wolf a lot of people
wearing some he keeps texting me that
that shit's happening
so whoever the [ __ ] Whitney especially
if she's got shows whoever dude
and so mmm you know what what was that
oh that was me
so the aftermath of the [ __ ] numb of
the turtleneck [ __ ] was man I bought so
many towels and had to hand them out to
so many [ __ ] people it was really
lucrative Lee a bad idea for me excited
to [ __ ] buy a bunch of towels so when
you yeah when you were a turtleneck man
I was watching you know what I watch
that movie knives out I you know I want
to be in a movie like that because I
don't know man
I saw Chris Evans in it and he's good
he's good I like Chris Evans and there
was one part where he was like where
they were like wanted to interview him
and he didn't want to be interviewed and
he walked into the house anyway and he
looked at the interview guys anyone or
he wanted to be looked at the FBI guys
or where the [ __ ] the detectors and goes
like this or something and I was like it
would have been the [ __ ] if he just went
like this why don't people do that in
movies you know dude why don't people do
that in movies why don't they do extra
hardcore overacting for no reason [ __ ]
that's so funny that would be the [ __ ]
that I mean there was a guy who did that
one there was one actor who did that
that I know in a drama it rules of what
was that [ __ ] Bret Easton Ellis movie
rules of attraction one actor did that
and that guy's my idol he was
laughing through the whole scene and it
was like so weird because it was like
did he did he do that in the audition or
what I don't know what it was and I
don't know what the actor is I'd have to
look at it but it's just if you watch
that movie rules of attraction man I
love that movie James Van Van Der Beek
is [ __ ] awesome in that movie james
Van Der Beek is so good james Van Der
Beek's gonna win an Oscar one day and I
ain't ever [ __ ] around either one who
the actor was I was Russell Samms that
guy Richard dick guy I think was that
guy anyway
rules of attraction is a cool movie Bret
Easton Ellis's books are so [ __ ]
funny man he wrote American Psycho I
don't know if you know well you know
American cycle probably but like the
Christian Bale [ __ ] and I read that book
and then when the movies coming out I
was like I can't wait to [ __ ] see it
yeah and and and he was like he there
was like it there's like all whole
chapters of him talking about how much
he likes Phil Collins which is [ __ ]
hilarious dude
pretty soon Ellis just wrote that [ __ ] a
whole chapter of how good the [ __ ]
discography of Phil Collins is ah like
to take a break from writing a book and
then to write a chapter about the
discography of Phil Collins is literally
the most boss move of all time it's
quite simply the most boss move of all
time do you know what the most boss move
of all time was I recorded it last night
and put it on my Instagram if you can go
if you can look at it my Instagram story
has all the pictures from the Ice House
it's the last thing I post on my
Instagram story I'm gonna [ __ ] save
it save video and so this way I can just
post it on my Instagram the holy mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude always send it to you
guys this guy who is in that 70s show
duh the dad from the 70s show is [ __ ]
talking to this guy how about how he
owes him some money and how he would
need to I said that I just had to do
need some money and any [ __ ] - the
guys drinking wine and he takes and he's
bossing him out like he's bossing him up
he's giving him the busy sitting him
watching him and as an actor he goes and
he takes two fingers dips it in the
guy's wine and
and sniffs it in his nose that dude if
you can get to boss level [ __ ] if you
can get to Mach 10 boss level boss level
Mach 10 and dip dude it was so [ __ ]
hilarious cuz then the other actor drank
the wine anyway like you know they were
acting off you know like that's how guys
act off one guy makes a choice and he's
like oh you're gonna make that choice
okay well I'm gonna make this choice
then I'll still drink it I don't give a
[ __ ] about your fingers you ain't no
boss he [ __ ] stuck his fingers in his
wine and then sniffed it you don't do
that you don't [ __ ] know for no
reason put snort wine period wow it was
so boss he's me so therefore he's my
favorite actor the week actor of the
week dude we got to have actor of the
week dude Robocop the movie Robocop is
so [ __ ] ill it's one of my favorite
movies of all time the original one and
then I saw the one with Joel Kinnaman
which I love Joel Kinnaman and it was
still cool to see them do it with all
the technology now and the CGI and [ __ ]
but that original Robocop movie was so
[ __ ] good because it had like this
weird dark humor in it that the new one
didn't have the new ones more just a
straight-up action movie which I gets
the I get I get gets the box-office draw
but they did that with [ __ ] told the
new Total Recall to that [ __ ] movie
is one of my top movies of all time and
then they made it with Colin Farrell and
it was just a an action movie but man
the [ __ ] was funny it used to be it was
funny dude
wow he's sniffing the wine right here
dips everything I don't wanna [ __ ] with
the asal or whatever the [ __ ] his name
is dude in the 80s there was always a
bag at him Sal did not even income in
movies in real life you think I gotta
talk to Sal yeah dude
so um Robocop is the [ __ ] you know what
I want to do is a live stream watching a
movie with you guys like on either
Instagram live or yours or YouTube or
something
but it'll get taken down because of
extra rights or whatever I don't know
that sucks huh
oh well hey dude sometimes you have
ideas and they can't put them into real
life but uh you know and that's fine
life still rips ha ha
so uh so uh I went to the and I did the
ice house working on some new I have
about 25 minutes of new material that
I'm working on and then I have like 25
minutes of old [ __ ] that I throw in
there just because I need to fill out
the hour so I'm trying to fill it up I
got these dates coming up so I want to
start you know that's how I do it I
implement the new [ __ ] until the old
[ __ ] just falls to the wayside and so I
was in Pasadena man that ice house Club
is amazing I met Johnny buss who's the
[ __ ] owner of the Lakers and he was
there cuz he owns the ice house now um
which was [ __ ] wild as [ __ ] to meet
him nicest [ __ ] and the ice house that
Club is awesome man if you're in
Pasadena Pasadena area or even if you go
to like the Comedy Store in LA you gotta
go see sometimes and go see the [ __ ]
ice house man it's such an it's an
historic was it the first comedy it was
like one of the it was like it's old as
[ __ ] but it's really nice and that room
is electric so don't you go to the Ice
House you do material and it kills so
hard and then you go over and do it in
the comedy story you're like oh this
doesn't work dude the crowds are I don't
know what it is about rooms and [ __ ]
that just make they make people it's
conducive to left or like the laughs
actors like that the laughs actors like
that the the the ice houses like that
but bro the Comedy Store and The Improv
are not like that like you go up on the
improv you could have a good or bad
night depending on the crowd but if you
go up at the Comedy Store and you're not
funny you eat [ __ ] period doesn't matter
if the rooms good or not if you're not
funny at the Comedy Store
eh [ __ ] I feel like the comedy cellars
that way too although I haven't played
as much as I have the Comedy Store
but yeah something about these rooms
that hold like 110 like the cot like the
Comedy Store original room holds like
110 or 120 in the Comedy Cellar I was
like [ __ ] 90 anyway so I did the the
the the ice house it's a great a great
room and then and then I [ __ ] did you
see the Oscars man I've watched parasite
and I loved that movie but I thought the
main good thing about that movie was the
the screenplay and I thought it was
directed great and all that acting was
really great I [ __ ] liked the movie
and then this guy tweeted this thing
about it's such a bad tweet John Miller
is at Miller stream a man named bong
joon-ho wins Oscar for Best Original
Screenplay over Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood in 1917 acceptance speech was
great honor thank you then he proceeds
to give the rest of his speech in the
Korean these people are the destruction
of America
that's so bad to say you know like just
straight up what are you saying hey dude
trying to dig your own grave see it's
interesting that like mmm Trump has
really brought these [ __ ] out
you know bring him out bring him out
that's what their be yelling when the
barrels in the mouth that I wouldn't you
know that song that jay-z song never
knew what he was saying Burrell I was
like Burrell he's saying barrel I wish
he just said that's what just say saying
when the barrels in your mouth why
doesn't he do that why I don't know why
does he say I
I ain't into like him do his no way why
does he say that in a song don't know
but he does yeah ha ha since secure
always how he laughs it's ok ok ain't
into like into it's no way anyway
um set without the Jews that's why the
Jews bought out a property should have
bought a property in DUMBO but I did it
cuz did you bought it and now kicking
myself ain't into like in dudes no way
so yeah and then I wrote G Jesus I wrote
well there's a ridiculous tweet Jesus
Christ it's weird to think like
extremely left and then also it's weird
to think extremely right like when then
you see people like [ __ ] what's that
girl's name Bryn [ __ ] who's the girl
who played Captain Marvel and she's just
like a guy looked at me now and you're
like Kylie let's just meet in the middle
I you know or or or Joaquin Phoenix
acceptance speech where he's just like
thanks for the Oscar don't drink milk
Casey yeah thanks thanks for the Oscar
thanks for the Oscar stop squeezing cows
Casey yeah pivot Pyung whether we're
talking there's a part where he was like
whether we're talking about black people
or cows like and how do we not miss that
like it's all because we love O'Keefe he
was a super talented guy and obviously
his heart is in the right place and
obviously he's such a great [ __ ] guy
just cares about lots of [ __ ] but like
if I went up there like if I for some
reason went up and was just like guys
thanks so much for the Oscar this is
amazing but also black people and cows
need rights
you'd be like Kay we should to give him
the Oscar whether we're talking about
Koreans or animals like hey how did we
miss it it's because dude you give
people they make it they make they like
if the rock said it it would be okay
if a comedian said it they'd be done
dude if Rogen or anybody went up there
and just were like said what he said
they'd be like why is he comparing black
people to cows um these acceptance
speeches are just a love Joaquin Phoenix
I'm not even talking about his but these
acceptance speeches are just [ __ ] so
awful you know once they get to that
point you're oh great oh great
no well I'd like to thank this person
that person I'd like to thank that and
you know once they get to that point
you're like oh here it comes the
destruction of the end oh boy
and the thing is in the rights and if
you we've got war and oh you are wearing
a one hundred and seventy thousand
dollar dress okay bye
what if he just really did went up said
you know he walked up said thank you so
much black people and cows need rights
and [ __ ] in in it nickname you need a
lien on a nickname next up the even the
guy who does the next up okay oh okay
well next up [ __ ] Colin Firth is
gonna gives you a boy gives the Award
for Best Picture
that's him doing King's Speech for those
of you that haven't heard the [ __ ]
god some this I should have just called
this podcast sounds um so yeah man these
I don't know I don't know how but but
but this guy what I don't understand the
problem with bong joon-ho winning and
then saying great honor thank you and
then these people destruction of America
he went up to tweet John Miller went on
to tweet these people are obviously not
Koreans but those in Hollywood a warning
a for a foreign film that Stokes flames
of class warfare over two films I
thought were more does
Irving Lee simply reserving simply to
show how woke they are oh that should be
clear from the rest of what I tweeted
about tonight's direction you know okay
man you don't vote for that you're the
host of something on blaze TV yeah now I
think um I don't know who this guy is
whatever fine I'm sure maybe his hearts
in the right place I have no [ __ ]
idea but sounds bad tweet sounds bad
also if you're gonna argue anything
about any screenplay that was that to me
and I I didn't see all the movies but
that was that movie's screenplay was so
good
if you have a gripe with that movie and
and it's the screenplay I don't know
where your [ __ ] head is man it's also
not like to say that he won because
Hollywood is woke I guess maybe why cuz
he's Korean I guess I don't know weird
weird that he's saying that weird they
just pick in that battle I think cuz
that movie was [ __ ] awesome and how
cute was the guy who won it when he won
he was just like oh and then he [ __ ]
was like talking about all the other
guys who were when he was like Martin
Scorsese you know I I can't believe I'm
standing it with you or whatever the
[ __ ] he said I don't know it doesn't
matter but it was cute as [ __ ] man
God that guy looks so polite
God bah bong joon-ho looks so polite he
looks like he's never [ __ ] eating
something and gone yeah even if it was
gross he's so polite like he [ __ ] for
sure eats at people's houses and he's
like what a wonderful meal the whole
time but no matter what it is they'll be
like this is a car this is this is the
cardboard [ __ ] this is a cardboard
and he's like ah what a wonderful meal
that's how he looks have you guys seen
the host it's so good and snowpiercer is
so good that movie should have been
[ __ ] you guys guys he's snowpiercer
it's so good with Chris Evans
but I got it I wish I could see that
movie again I never watched movies twice
[ __ ] that dude mm-hmm
one time in high school my buddy wanted
to see he saw Braveheart and every time
people come over watch Braveheart and I
was like dude you watch him we watch at
one time and how you go through that
[ __ ] [ __ ] again
Braveheart of all movies to watch over
and over again what's wrong with you
guy gets his [ __ ] dick cut off at the
end ruined it spoiler alert or maybe
they cut his a Tommy open you never
really know actually Twitter was [ __ ]
nuts had to read all do read and then
I'll talk about how this happened uh-huh
a look around you it's a wireless world
are you even listening to this podcast
right now do you have your wireless [ __ ]
in it's a wireless world and everyone
needs a great pair of wireless earbuds
but before you go drop in hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
the wireless earbuds from Raycom you
already know ray Connor your blood start
at about half the price as any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as other
top audio brands you know and Ray Khan's
latest model e 25 is their best one yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit uh they are really
good I tried them when I was working out
and it was like I was in a world of
music but it was great man and even when
you're just like it and they don't fall
out to some of these other ones they
fall out and this is the truth I don't
know my ears are weird but these ones
didn't fall out so that was amazing
um you heard me talk about the company
was founded by Ray J and celebrities
like Snoop Dogg and cardi B are obsessed
with Rey Khan's pick up a pair and see
where all the hype is about now's the
time to get the latest and greatest from
Ray Khan get 15% off your order up by
Raycom / Congrats that's by raike on.com
/ congrats for 15% offer a con wireless
earbuds by rakin comm / congrats roman
most guys have tried different ways to
last longer but saying the Pledge of
Allegiance
in your head or counting backwards from
ten doesn't always work my buddy and I
in high school we used to talk about how
we would be like think of Calvin and
Hobbes and we just be like Calvin and
Hobbes Calvin and Hobbes and then we
were like what if when we were having
sex we said it out loud and then we
laughed and we laughed
these folks at Roman a men's health
company are changing the game with Roman
swipes the secret to longer-lasting sex
Roman swipes are clinically proven way
to last longer in bed they effective
easy to use and fast-acting but don't
require a prescription that means you
don't have to go and get it that means
you don't have to be embarrassed Roman
can ship swipes to you and discreet
unmarked packaging see that's why it's
awesome in each package is small enough
to hide in your wallet for whenever you
need it
whenever you get lucky they're super
easy to use just take swipes out of the
package swipe it on let it dry and
you're good to go that's it get $10 off
your first order of swipes and free
2-day shipping at get Roman comm slash
babies that's get Roman comm / babies
for $10 off and free 2-day shipping get
Roman comm / babies you guys need that
because you don't want to [ __ ] you
listen you don't want a Berber too soon
dude Berber and too soon is the worst
especially when you're one of those guys
who's like you think you got it going on
but then the but then the [ __ ] is
banging and you're like here we go but
hey but then it just goes on baby I'm
gonna hit it all night mom
whoops Calvin and anyway I wish Katz was
nominated for an Oscar they had to be
nominated for best something no that's
nothing no that would've been hilarious
if they were nominated for anything so I
did a tweet this was crazy to me this is
our sensitive the world is this was
crazy to me I wrote I did a thing I put
on my Instagram TV and it was a clip of
me kind of just messing with the
audience you could look at all my oh you
can look at it on YouTube too and I was
talking to these people in the crowd
they were they were they turned out they
were down these thing called my [ __ ]
not my only fans
can goddamn why do I always want to call
it that it's called only fans for those
either I don't know what only fans is
you can go on and subscribe to chicks
and they show you their [ __ ] fried
butterfly and bobaloo bees and you can
do it for like $9.99 a month or whatever
the [ __ ]
by the way that always tripped me who
the [ __ ] is getting tricked by the $9.99
it's $10 dude if I ever have a company I
don't want it to be $9.99 I wanted to be
[ __ ] 10 bucks as a matter of fact
[ __ ] that I'm gonna make it 1001 when I
was a kid I would always be like why
does it say 999 it's ten bucks won't
they just say ten bucks and my mom will
be like well that's because it's you
know what makes it seem like it's less
money I'm like it's one cent less money
dude what kind of [ __ ] idiot is like
well that's trooper dun dun da lows oh
you [ __ ] idiots dude even as a
[ __ ] children's I knew that even as a
[ __ ] children's I knew that I was
[ __ ] for one of my first words was
like why did it made it a [ __ ] 1999
oh and it only two hundred dollars my
mom was like well because people think
it's less money definitely one sinaloa
so dumb dude if you're buying some [ __ ]
that's 999 because you think that it's
less entitled in ten dollars that's once
and so anyway you can subscribe on only
fans for [ __ ] $9.99 or $15.99 or
[ __ ] $2.99 or whatever the [ __ ] it is
if the girl has a dozen of that good of
a body it maybe it's less money I don't
know her [ __ ] duck lips are bad it's
the less money or maybe it's more money
if you're like [ __ ] I don't know I
feel like Persian guys love all that
[ __ ] Persian guys not my only friends
but Persian guys loved the [ __ ] oh
damn she put all that much makeup on
that's the [ __ ] amazing bro she's out
to go she's out to go out tonight bro oh
man she put even more collagen in her
lip dawg that's it man I want my girl
looking like a Simpson dawg that's crazy
bro she did her hair really nice dawg
look at that man look how much
dippity-do she used dog Oh dog that's
awesome look at that outfit bro she's
got three outfits on at the same time
I'm Doug she's got an outfit on and then
on top of that she's got an alpha run
and then on top of that dog she's got
another outfit on dog and then she she
didn't even use makeup Doug she used
paint on her face she used house paint
dog on her face
[ __ ] contouring dog she used white and
black paint and then she told her doctor
to put straight up cement in her lips
dog she's so hot she can't even keep her
head up because of the house paint and
cement in her mouth dog
she basically drags her [ __ ] face on
the ground dark and she pushes it
forward and she's sweating so hard
because she's got three offices on Doc
what the [ __ ] was I even talking about
oh yeah only fans um only fans so this
girl was talking about how she does only
fans and I knew what it was kind of but
I didn't really know and and I was like
and she's like I'm on only fans and I
was like oh you're on that [ __ ]
so I was kind of like not roasting her
but kind of just having fun with her in
the audience to make a fun of it it's on
YouTube you can look at it they'll
[ __ ] add the link or something on the
bottom and they don't want fire and
heaven get rid of but and so I was like
so I tweeted something and I wrote god
this is so everyone's so sensitive this
is crazy I wrote I'm on only fans cuz it
was on my mind I'm on only fans can't
wait to show you my tits for 40 bucks
thinking how funny would it be if me a
39 year old can be male comedian not gay
straight like not trying to [ __ ] pimp
other like dudes so they could see my
tits
aka chest cuz down half tits can't wait
to show you my tips for 40 bucks
would it would be [ __ ] funny if you
don't think a 49 year old or a 49 a 39
whoopsie my secrets out if you don't
think a 39 year old
showing his tits guy on only fans for 40
bucks it's funny then I can't help you I
can't help you especially if it already
has a [ __ ] successful career doing
something else
can't help you can't help you you don't
think that visual is funny or even the
idea no not even the visual to me the
visual is not even what's funny for a 39
year old guy who's successful in another
arena to be like gotta be on only fans
and show my tits for $40 you don't think
that's funny
what enough want nothing to do with you
you got me telling her want nothing to
do there now I'm out here spilling
caveman coffee on that that's how it's
pissing me off
right so thanks bro so I I tweeted that
and at first it was like you know was
getting a lot of traction I was like
that's funny I guess people think it's
funny and then people were like really
mad about it like actually like and it
wasn't the girls really that do only
fans like if some of the girls were like
haha let's [ __ ] but like these [ __ ]
guys I don't know we're like great stuff
here funny ass stuff man hilarity can't
stop laughing keep it up bro somebody
else like obviously sarcasm somebody
else wrote hysterical man like egging me
on and then some other guy was like oh
you're gonna [ __ ] some other people like
slut-shamed me oh you're gonna [ __ ]
you know we're out here getting killed
all right dude first of all to get the
fact to think about the fact to think
that um first of all to think that I'm
somehow making fun of only fans in that
tweet you just don't get the joke first
of all second of all if I am making fun
of only fans who gives a [ __ ] you gotta
be
you gotta be you make fun everything
comedians make fun of everything so shut
the relax you can be offended if you
want but you can't tell me not to say
some [ __ ] okay cuz I'm gonna now but
people were like people out are out here
getting killed you know because of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah okay cool man
I'm not making fun of that and also if I
was okay its Twitter but like to be it
just is like the the [ __ ] dudes that
were like trying to come to the rescue
are the worst like dude you're not
getting laid because you're the [ __ ]
friend guy you know you're not coming to
the defense of the people that could
[ __ ] come to their own defense by the
way you taking that away from women is
the prop is one of the problems like
women can [ __ ] can say no they can
they can do the [ __ ] when guys step in
and are like hey it's not right
you're being sexist dude I'll handle
this Dame I'll don't worry sweetheart
I'll handle this dude sit the [ __ ] down
girls can say [ __ ] you how about that
dude if they're equal then they can say
[ __ ] you how about that dude you cuck
and ask [ __ ] also its twitter
if you don't think something's funny on
twitter that's cuz it's twitter dude all
this [ __ ] I say on Twitter is not funny
it sucks it's cuz it's free you want to
see something funny
come see the act of [ __ ] worked out
complaining
every content is great dude it's like
III III it's so annoying when people
take it the wrong way I hate that I'm
making fun of me showing my tits and
people are like you know it's much
here's the other thing about it if you
think I'm making a fun of only fans and
you're mad because I say hey I joined
only fans I I can't wait to show my tits
for 40 dollars if you take that
that's literally what only fans is it's
literally what it is you're paying to
see girls show the bits and pieces so
I'm saying that so take that out of it
like the humor take the humor or
whatever you think out of it it's
literally what it is
therefore how are you mad at me for
saying quite literally what it is you're
mad all over the place for zero reason
and also it doesn't matter I'm [ __ ]
by the way get your [ __ ] money
no of course get your money get your
money get your money dude I think it's
[ __ ] awesome so awesome if you've got
tits and you want to charge dudes to see
them get that [ __ ] scrilla and I
barely say scrilla I barely say scrilla
but if you've got tits and you've got a
fried butterfly and you want to say hey
dude wanna see it for $11 and the dude
goes yup then rake it in
rake it in dude get $11 from this guy
get $11 from that guy get $11 from
another guy get $11 from the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that thinks he's defending women
but he's not because women can defend
themselves and then guess what you've
got $44 just for having tits dude I love
only fans and I love the girls on them
and if you're trying to act like I don't
then go [ __ ] yourself Chuck and that's
Adelaide jeremy renner sting I don't
[ __ ] you're not gonna put me in a hole
that I'm not in dude show that ass and
make $11 dude show that ass to a guy
collect $11 show that ass to another guy
who's married and sad collect $11 and
show that ass to another guy who thinks
he's defended women when women can
defend themselves and don't take their
autonomy away from it and make $11 and
then guess what you have $44 that's
lunch for two days [ __ ] I mean dude
you're not gonna put me in a [ __ ]
hole dude I'm climbing the [ __ ] out that
hole and that's why we listen to this
podcast and that's why we listen to this
podcast dude because we break down all
of the real issues [ __ ] NPR [ __ ] all the
podcasts where people [ __ ] talk about
worldly events dude
sokka mall dude we talk about the real
[ __ ] like only fans and [ __ ] whatever
wait doesn't matter dude
what I do know is I [ __ ] love Jeremy
Renner for making that song
I [ __ ] love Jeremy Renner for making
that song he's a talented actor and I'm
his biggest [ __ ] fan dude would drink
my baby's shipstation
when you're selling online getting your
orders out can be a real pain how do you
keep track of who gets what which ship
and carrier should you use are you
getting the best rates look there's so
many questions the answer shipstation
calm that's why you need it
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your product out fast to
keep your customers happy ship station
makes it easy ship station helps you get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep your customers
happy I use ship station for all my
merch so have you gotten a life ripped
shirt well thank you ship station you
get it quickly and it's all good my fans
always tweet me about how fast they get
their stuff sometimes the stuff gets the
next day anyway ship station is the way
to go it's so easy they offer big
discounts on shipping costs any business
can access the same postage discounts
that are usually reserved for large
fortune 500 companies you'll always know
you're getting the best deal and right
now congratulations with Crystal Lea
listeners can try ship station free for
60 days when you use offer code Congrats
there's absolutely no risk you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
congrats that's shipped station comm and
then enter offer code congrats ship
station comm make ship happen power dot
being fit and healthy is the goal but
being sore or in pain from workouts
sucks ok you can spend a ton of money to
hire a per
masseuse or you could do what I did and
check out power dot it's actually really
cool I have it on right now on my
forearm here and but it puts a modern
spin on clinically proven muscle
stimulation it's the first of its kind
power dot is built around an intuitive
mobile app which I have right here on my
phone and it hooks to bluetooth it
provides these user with preset programs
like design to speed up recovery improve
athletic performance reduced pain and
Rehab from injury I use it a lot on my I
actually use are my legs before I go to
sleep because I have restless leg
syndrome and if I do it before I go to
sleep I don't get that weird feeling on
my legs and I can fall asleep quicker
but the app guides you through the
process with pre designed programs like
massage and pad placement photos for
places like lower back it's just it's
good for all that stuff traveling the
peridot is extremely convenient I know
you could use it you put it on your legs
when you travel a lot of people get
cramp traveling for too long anyway it's
used by cyclists and CrossFit CrossFit
athletes and it's a solution for pain
management training recovery and injury
rehabilitation power dot offers us
customers a free 30 day trial plus an
additional 20 percent off for our
listeners go to power dot-com / congrats
and use code Congrats I check out for
20% off of your order that's power
dot-com / Congrats
and the code congrats anyway dude I
don't know I love when you get that
money dude stop with that 1099 [ __ ]
though man
oh oh shush shush you're an insult no
shush be quiet
what was I talking about about the
[ __ ] man how sexiest future this the
guy future I think
[ __ ] sexy I'm a dude and I'll say it
I don't care
futures a sexy guy bro look at that you
know how you know he's sexy the sexiest
guy has not that good body he's fine
his body's fine but like it's not like
ripped and god damn that guy's sexy when
he said sensational when he said that
dude I was like oh my god I'm not even
[ __ ] gay but boy yo y'all yelling he
goes sensational and I'm not even gay
but Braca CAC CAC CAC dude that guy when
he goes sensational I was like goddamn
dude you know when he does that can you
bring it up dude and chicks if if I was
him whenever I had sex with the new
chick and she said how was it I was a
sensational when he when he says what
does he say about the new song he's like
never loud in my home was a lot of my
[ __ ] you know so [ __ ] disrespectful
priorities in all the wrong places
I got sensational right here sensational
I'm gonna play it dude this [ __ ] is got
to be a sting here we go here we go
we're playing listener oh wow dude the
laughs oh oh wow dude that's so sexy
dude
sensational is that towards you looking
for relational oh and even somebody
under the thing under it says he said it
coolest [ __ ] yeah that's true he did
nobody can say sensational cooler than
that man you know what dude
if I don't know who's interviewing but
if I [ __ ] interviewed some guy and he
and that was the answer that he gave me
I would pack up everything right there
and leave and be like I have to go
you're the sexiest man alive
he should have won people's magazine
sexiest men alive he should have just
been a [ __ ] picture of him with that
microphone in his face and you'd be like
oh yes cuz he said the sensational thing
right
oh wow these guys wore turtlenecks all
together look at this
myself and my mates being turtleneck
linkers it's a British here at Gears of
War look up that wow they got [ __ ]
turtlenecks on congratulations PAH there
you go repping that [ __ ] wet
lifestyle do it you know what those
[ __ ] turtlenecks are I became gay
when he said it the guy gets exactly
exact and became gay that guy mmm
because that's so hot dude I don't give
a [ __ ] I'll tell you when a guy's hot
that's hot
futures of sexiest man in the whole
[ __ ] world right now
nobody sexier the future dude he [ __ ]
wears fur and [ __ ] and doesn't I gotta
get to that level dude I know I always
talk about this man and I got a jacket
the other day that's long and it's
[ __ ] mustard yellow so watch the [ __ ]
out okay and then I got another long
green flannel and I'm just saying watch
the [ __ ] out okay because my [ __ ] you
know what guy I gotta do I gotta wear a
[ __ ] long shirt and no pants that's
what I got to do and go shopping for
like groceries and when people be like
do have pants on I just go like this you
don't get it bro um also I should start
smoking [ __ ] so much weed and just be
that guy mmm
Timothy sha'lame I like Timothy sha'lame
man definitely call it selamat Timothy
chill am it but uh
look at this this this [ __ ] [ __ ] that
look news AV Club nobody knows what to
do with Tim and the shell amaze Oscar
look huh he just put on a he wore a
tracksuit dude that's the [ __ ] that he's
I like that he's doing that man cuz it's
so annoying everyone gets all dressed up
at everyone so [ __ ] annoying I
brought some of these dresses they got a
stand out who was the [ __ ] girl that
wore the hood she look like a Star Wars
character Janelle Monae is that her name
and it's like every time he showed the
audience my I went right to her it's
like oh how about [ __ ] a spike Aleya
he wore a purple and yellow tux with 24
on the lapel for Kobe Bryant
hey dude and a [ __ ] driver's cap and
Denis odd he made it he did a.m. what
did he present what did he present
whatever he presented [ __ ] the guy
came up and it was like so beautiful I
think was bond Jun or whatever the guys
name is he won and then and then he
[ __ ] walked off row into the moment
ruin the moment you know looked awful so
bits with the hate love [ __ ] there's
a picture of him with the hate love bare
not brass knuckles and he's doing it
like this [ __ ] with the Kobe Bryant
journey by the way Kobe right if you saw
that he would be like what's doing Q
Doon to hood it's free conch you can do
it but to Doon like people think they
really out here saying [ __ ] just because
they have hate and love on their [ __ ]
that's hilarious man what do you what
what oh you're both those hate and love
pickle
anyway dude you know we have to [ __ ]
say about that
sensation this is looking for exactly
yeah
that was the word I was looking for did
you know that um my brother's texting me
he's like here's a cut of your special
and then he read I told him to make a
few changes and he says my brother
directed my special and he says he sent
me the link and he writes here's the
password check it out and he writes it's
perfect so don't say it's not you know
dude 'some at daliyah you should listen
to my brother's podcast is really good
it's called Matthew Lee is confused this
is this is still my this is still my
favorite Oscar thing here that has
happened was when [ __ ] John Travolta
goddamn dude was when John Travolta did
miss messed up the idina menzel name let
me break this down it's going so well is
my fit is my favorite part like ease
it's going like legitimately swimmingly
like he's killing it
he's very eloquent he's got his
hairpiece on and it's looking match and
he's got his [ __ ] cool talks on this
is what he really knows he's starting to
kill it too right here when he says
wickedly wickedly talented who won and
only this is what I think went on in his
head right now he's forgetting how to
pronounce her name he knows it and he
thinks you know what I'm gonna use all
my confidence and I'm gonna start it
with the word wickedly and own my [ __ ]
and by the time I get to her name it's
gonna come out right because I've said
it before and then it doesn't and that
to me honestly
yeah that moment look at the frame when
he's looking to his left he's just like
okay well I [ __ ] it up and that moment
was the [ __ ] moment where you know
how you seen judge revoked a lot bald a
lot lately he was just like I [ __ ] it I
you know I'm that moment I guarantee
that moment was what made him realize I
don't need to [ __ ] wear a hairpiece
have [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know I mean bro
he I mean the build-up is the smile
shall place in my heart
ready the muse just killing it and for
the songs that create their most
memorable moments look at that okay to
perform the oscar-nominated gorgeous I
think he realizes he can't remember her
name when he says gorgeous yes it was
Gor gorgeous Lee cuz he had some ice on
his mind it was like a little too long
and said gorgeous it and then it go and
then he was like I'm [ __ ] I don't
know what it is
and then when he did you know what unuse
my comic that's the confidence kicking
in and then didn't have it though did
the dealt the zeem literally just say
[ __ ] Frank Drebin
you know what I mean ah [ __ ] it though
it was way better why do you say Frank
Drebin he'd be like I was thinking about
[ __ ] naked gun lieutenant Drebin
please welcome lieutenant Drebin that
would've been amazing and then everyone
would have clapped still and you would
relate you're [ __ ] [ __ ] still
clapped at least own it like that oh
don't ever [ __ ] stutter syllables
just pick a new name and say please
welcome lieutenant Frank Drebin and then
she comes let it go let it go this so
great adele dazeem 'he's you know oh his
kids were like oh no but the other one
was good the other another one was good
at the end James Cameron when 20 more
when he wins for tight
with the tails you know deep-diving
camera system when he does this my
lovely wife Linda nice our two beautiful
children social Joseph so sweet
well he was married to Linda Hamilton I
didn't know that hey original still
losers my parents who are here tonight
Phillip Phillip and Shirley Cameron mom
dad there's no way I'm mouth the kind I
can express to you what I'm feeling
right now my heart is full to bursting
Wow except to say I like that I'm the
king
[Music]
my whole thing don't we'll never will my
whole thing is never will and he goes
I'm the king of the world and that's one
of those God it's amazing these guys
whose butt I mean one of them I mean so
talented makes creates these worlds and
then they just get up on stage and you
can see they're not used to it and
they're a little bit nervous and then
just it's funny to being a KU stand-up
comedian help so much just in life man
it just helps so much you don't give a
[ __ ] about stuff like you could tell he
was like oh this seemed like a better
idea in my head when I [ __ ] cuz it's
a line in the movie and then when he
said he's I got maybe it's insecure and
but it's like if you were a comedian and
you did it and you were out there anyone
I'm the king of the world like I'm just
a bad idea you'd literally like I'll
whatever I [ __ ] that up and then it
would be fine you know but instead a
disease he just says the wickedly
talented the wouldn't only a diseased
Aziz Ansari Wow dude the Oscars are
hilarious dude
when Brando brought up the remember this
[ __ ] I don't but it's a thing right here
when he won for
when he went for Godfather obviously
forgive
he brought up an Indian woman
native-american whatever I don't know
how to dress very regretfully cannot
accept this very generous award Wow and
the reasons for this beam are the
treatment of American Indians today by
the film industry excuse me
Wow Wow Wow people boo
try to make a point here people boo that
dress is awesome this evening and that
we will in the future our hearts and our
understandings generosity thank you damn
dude he even show up and he was like
yeah you'll do it you go talk about
wounded name if I get a [ __ ] Oscar
dude there's no way I'm going up to
accept it
I'm sending [ __ ] for real David
Caruso and he's gonna go up and he's
gonna he's gay no he's gonna say he's
gonna say sorry but Chris D'Elia can't
be here and he's gonna say he wanted to
but that but he went to the doctor the
other day and it turns out he's just too
sick with it and then he puts his
[ __ ] glasses on and pivots
and then that happens and then they say
coming up award for best cinematographer
dude that would be the [ __ ] dude he went
to the doctor the other day and it
wasn't home so it's okay and it turns
out he's too sick with it
[Applause]
[ __ ] yeah dude uh anyway dude I guess
that's it you know
sensational um good podcast it's
sensational
and it's all good um I guess that's it
uh what am I gonna do here is uh oh yeah
you gotta come see me at West Palm Beach
you got come see me in Brea you got come
see me
other places I'm doing I'm doing this
[ __ ] text me at eight one eight three
two sorry eight one eight two three nine
7087 West Palm Beach
Robinson Milk Robinson V Mississippi
Rona Park California Brea Las Vegas I'll
see you there soon have a good one and
remember my babies remember my babies
Romero my babies here we go sensation
you guys are great
[Music]